Our next speaker is James Muller, who is Professor
of Political Science at the University of
Alaska in Anchorage, and Academic Chairman
of the Churchill Center.
Dr. Muller served as a White House Fellow
in the US Department of Education in the Reagan
Administration.
His teaching, research, and writing have,
for many years, focused on the statesmanship
and writings of Winston Churchill.
He has published new editions of 2 of Churchill's
interwar books of Essays, Thoughts and Adventures,
and Great Contemporaries.
He is currently at work on a new edition of
Churchill's autobiography, My Early Life,
as well as a book on Churchill's writings,
titled The Education of Winston Churchill.
He is also preparing a new edition of Churchill's
book The River War, an historical account
of the re-conquest of the Sudan, which will
be republished later this year.
This is also the theme of his talk today,
titled Lessons from Churchill's The River
War.
Please welcome to the podium Dr. James Muller.
James Muller: Ladies and gentlemen, it's a
delight to be here.
Richard mentioned technology, and I'm just
waiting for this.
President Arn and fellow Churchillians.
I'm delighted to be in Denver for this important
conference.
I want to thank Larry Arn, whom I first met
more than 40 years ago, and also Hillsdale
College, which I first visited more than 40
years ago, for bringing us together to learn
from Winston Churchill.
I should say that my interest in Churchill
goes back to about that same era, to Winston
Churchill's 100th birthday, when I was a graduate
student.
Those of us who were living together out on
the edge of town decided to have a birthday
party for Winston Churchill.
We listened to Edward R. Murrow's record with
Churchill's speeches.
We bought some tomato juice and some vodka,
which was all we could afford, and when our
guests came we said, "Bloody Mary?"
I think I had a Virgin Mary.
But after listening to Churchill's speeches,
we decided that, I decided ought to learn
some more about Churchill.
I would add one book to those that have been
suggested among the first one might read,
which is Thoughts and Adventures.
That was the first one I read, and I'm still
hooked.
But I agree with Richard Langworth that my
early life is a wonderful place to begin.
I always say when someone asks me, "What book
should I read about Churchill?"
I say, "Read books by Churchill first.
There are lots of people writing books about
him, but his own books are the best.
Now, I'm going to speak about a time in Churchill's
early life, which has been referred to a bit,
up till now.
But it's way back in 1898, when Churchill
first went to Africa as a young cavalry officer
and as a war correspondent.
He took part in Brittain's campaign to rescue
the Sudan from an Islamist regime.
His 15 newspaper dispatches from that campaign,
which he wrote in purple ink with a fountain
pen after long marches through the Sahara
Desert in high summer when the temperature
was more than 110 degrees during the day,
on letter paper he had borrowed from the British
Embassy in Cairo, were published eventually
in the Morning Post in London.
After serving in Africa, Churchill left the
Army, and he spent a year writing a book on
the campaign.
Of the 5 books he wrote before entering parliament
in 1901 at the age of 26, this book is the
most impressive.
Churchill called it The River War.
Three years after it was published, he abridged
it into a single volume for the 2nd edition
in 1902.
Seven chapters disappeared completely, and
passages were cut from every chapter, including
his own adventures and his controversial judgments.
The full text of this book has been out of
print since 1902.
Twenty-five years ago, I was on my wedding
trip.
I was sitting in the British library, and
I made the discovery that the expensive new
edition of all of Churchill's writings that
I had bought had only an abridged version
of this book, The River War.
If I had known Richard Langworth better, he
would have told me that already.
But it was a few months to go before I actually
met him in person.
I looked up this edition, this unabridged
2-volume edition, of The River War in the
north reading room of the British library,
and discovered that it had many, many wonderful
things that I had missed in reading the shorter
version of the book.
This new edition of The River War that I decided
somebody ought to prepare, and I ended up
being the one, 25 years ago, is now finally
nearing completion, and is going to be published
in 2 volumes by St. Augustine's Press.
On these slides, and also in the new edition,
the passages that were left out of the 2nd
edition are going to be in red, while the
passages that remained in the 2nd edition
after the cuts are in black.
That way, you'll have some sense of what you've
been missing if you've never read the full
2-volume edition of The River War.
Churchill, whose regiment was stationed in
India in 1898, got to the Sudan in time to
ride in the cavalry charge in the climactic
battle of Omdurman across the river from Khartoum.
Now high civilization in Egypt goes back thousands
of years, even before the glory of Greece
and Rome.
It was all made possible by the river, without
which Egypt would be only a desert.
The river is the Nile, and its annual miracle
of its life-giving flood captivated men even
before the time of Cleopatra.
I've borrowed Paul Klee's painting as the
background for our slides this afternoon.
Churchill was struck by the beauty of the
sunsets on the Nile.
He wrote in The River War, "the wonderful
flame pictures baffle memory and are beyond
recall."
Egypt is a strip of civilization along the
Nile, broadening out into the delta just before
it flows into the Mediterranean Sea.
To remind you of the geography of Northeastern
Africa, and incidentally after making this
map I am impressed forever with Martin Gibert's
efforts at map making.
This 1 map I've made took hours and hours,
and I don't think it's quite as good as Martin's.
But I hope it'll be good enough to give you
an idea of the 2 branches of the Nile River,
the White Nile, and the Blue.
The White Nile begins in the great lakes of
Central Africa, losing much of it's water
through evaporation as it flows leisurely
through the jungle.
If you've seen The African Queen, you know
what the jungle is like, choked with tangled
vegetation called sudd on it's way north.
The Blue Nile, on the other hand, is quite
different.
It rises in the mountains of Ethiopia.
When the shows melt, it comes rushing downstream
through a canyon.
The two branches of the Nile meet at Khartoum,
which means "the elephant's trunk."
Four fifths of the water that flows downstream
from Khartoum comes from the Blue Nile, and
it carries the silt that makes the Nile Delta
so fertile.
That flow is seasonal.
It accounts for the flood that irrigates the
banks of the river hundreds of miles north
in Egypt.
Then only 1 other tributary flows into the
river north of Khartoum, the Atbarah River,
which dries up into disconnected, stagnant
pools in the summertime.
Then the Nile flows through the Sahara Desert
for 800 miles without gaining a single drop
of water.
Here's another map of Egypt and the Sudan,
though this one doesn't have the newly formed
nation of South Sudan, which separated from
the southern third of the Sudan in 2009.
The right to divide the water from the Nile,
which is critical to Ethopia, Egypt, and both
Sudans, remains a matter of contention and
high level negotiation.
In the 19th century, slavery was the most
important institution in the economy of the
Sudan.
After the fall of Napoleon, Egypt, which was
nominally part of the Ottoman Empire, decided
to become an imperial power in imitation of
European imperialism.
Even the Pharoahs had never been able to conquer
the Sudan.
The Sahara Desert was a daunting obstacle.
But in the early 1800s, an Egyptian army managed
to go up the Nile, capture Khartoum, and impose
a harsh rule on the Sudanese.
The Egyptians took over the slave trade.
Before long, the Sudanese rose in rebellion
against Egyptian misrule.
Muhammad Ahmed, the son of a boat builder,
became a prophet, and he rallied his countrymen
to throw off the invaders corrupt version
of Islam.
Proclaiming himself the Mahdi, he aspired
to make the whole world, including Cairo,
Constantinople, and even London, submit to
the true faith.
Churchill thinks the Sudanese had good cause
to rebel, and his treatment of the Mahdi in
The River War is remarkably generous, as this
quotation suggests.
The first edition of The River War was illustrated
by Angus McNeill, a fellow officer who, like
Churchill, had gone to Harrow School and to
Sandhurst.
His drawings were left out of the 2nd edition
of the book, and have never been reproduced
in any other edition, but they're going to
reappear in this new one.
The Mahdi's soldier's were called the Dervishes.
The term Dervish means a religious medicant
who has taken vows of poverty and austerity.
McNeill here depicts a Dervish spearman wearing
his customary garb, a patched cloak, or jibba,
and carrying primitive weapons.
Meanwhile, the Kadive who ruled Egypt for
the Ottoman sultan, was a spendthrift.
He borrowed huge sums from European lenders.
These debts and the heavy taxes that were
required to pay interest in them provoked
a Nationalist revolt in Egypt, which was led
by an Egyptian army officer named Arabi Pasha.
You see, the Europeans, especially the British
and the French, were afraid that if the rebels
reneged on this debt and they came to power,
then all the creditors would lose their money.
So the British and French governments agreed
to suppress the revolt.
But then the French fleet declined to take
part in the campaign and sailed away from
Alexandria Harbor.
The British bombarded the harbor and put an
end to the rebellion, and Britain became responsible
for ruling Egypt.
Sir Evelyn Baring, later Lord Cromer, was
the British advisor to the Kadive, who ruled
nominally for the Ottoman sultan.
What this meant is that the Kadive had to
follow whatever advice Cromer gave him.
Cromer was later a mentor to the young Winston
Churchill.
Cromer tried to put the Egyptian economy on
a sound foundation, and to do that he knew
that Egypt would have to abandon the Sudan
despite the growing power of the Mahdi, because
Egypt simply couldn't afford to keep it.
Back in London, the liberal administration
of Prime Minister Gladston urged Egypt to
give up the Sudan.
But evacuating the Europeans in Khartoum became
urgent as the Mahdist army surrounded the
capital.
Charles Gordon, who had made his name in China,
and had battled the slave trade while he was
governor of the Sudan, was sent back to Khartoum
as the British envoy to save the garrisons.
But Gladston sent him reluctantly, and he
sent him without any support.
At first, Gordon's reputation awed the Dervish
army.
They were afraid that a British arm would
follow.
But when they saw that he was only 1 man on
a camel, they tightened their grip on Khartoum.
For his part, Gordon was stubborn, and he
tried to hold the capital rather than just
evacuating the Europeans.
His situation in Khartoum became dire, but
Gladston was loathe to lift a finger to help.
An Austrian army officer, Rudolph Slatin,
commanded an Egyptian army in Darfur.
His soldiers became demoralized because the
army was commanded by a Christian.
So he told them he was converting to Islam.
But his Egyptians were still no match for
the Dervishes, and Slatin was defeated and
captured by the Mahdi.
Slatin, then a prisoner, wrote to Gordon,
who desperately needed assistance from somebody
who had the kind of military experience and
ability that Slatin had, offering to escape
from the Mahdi and to join Gordon in defending
Khartoum.
But Gordon rejected Slatin's offer with contempt,
because Slatin had forsaken his God.
Churchill, in The River War, criticizes Gordon,
who was admired widely in Britain as a Christian
hero, for rejecting Slatin's offer.
Gladston was finally forced to send out, not
1, but 2 relief expeditions to save Gordon,
1 going through the desert, and the other
1 along the river.
But the expeditions arrived too late.
Gordon was put to death by the Dervishes,
and he became a martyr.
His death, Churchill says, left the British
discouraged.
The Mahdi was triumphant in Kartoum, and he
ruled over all of the Sudan.
A few months later, though, the Mahdi died,
and he was succeeded by Abdullah, who was
a soldier rather than a prophet.
Abdullah became the Khalif, or Khalifa.
Churchill doesn't find him as sympathetic
a figure as the Mahdi, but he admits he did
have some civilized qualities, and he's impressed
with his statecraft.
Six years later the empire of the Dervishes
reached its greatest extent, ruling much of
present-day Sudan and South Sudan, and slivers
of Ethiopia and Eretria as well.
Abdulla wasn't actually able to conquer Egypt,
but he did defeat the Egyptians in a war with
King John, and he was master of the Sudan.
The British disbanded the old Egyptian army
that had fared so ill at the hands of the
Dervishes.
Cromer wanted to reconquer the Sudan, but
not right away.
A new Egyptian army began to grow up under
British command, and Herbert Kitchener became
Sirdar of the Anglo-Egyptian army.
Kitchener's intelligence chief, General Wingate,
and an Austrial priest in Dervish captivity,
Father Ohrwalder, collected information about
the Mahdi's regime.
Not only did this intelligence assist the
eventual campaign to reconquer the Sudan.
But also with Wingate's help, Ohrwalder published
a book about the Dervishes that shocked European
readers.
Slatin published another book, Fire and Sword
in the Sudan after Escaping from the Mahdi's
Camp, which was translated into English.
These books helped turn public opinion in
Britain in favor of helping Egypt to reconquer
the Sudan.
Meanwhile, the Ethiopians dealt a crushing
defeat to a modern Italian army at Adowa,
damaging the reputation of Europeans in Africa.
Also, a French expedition traversing the continent
from west to east threatened to prevent a
British Cape to Cairo railroad by creating
instead an unbroken blue line of French colonies
across Africa instead.
So early in 1896, Britain resolved to help
Egypt reconquer the Sudan.
The Anglo-Egyptian army with British officers
commanding native Egyptian and Sudanese troops
crossed the border from Egypt into the Sudan.
Kitchener began his campaign by reconquering
the northernmost province of the Sudan, Dongola,
in 1896.
The progress of the army was eagerly followed
in Britain.
Kitchener had the latest weapons, iron-clad
gunboats on the Nile with machine guns and
canons.
They followed the army south along the river.
McNeill's illustrations show the advances
in naval engineering between 1885 and 1898.
But it was difficult to ascend the Nile, and
the boats had to be towed, or even disassembled
and portaged around cataracts of the river.
Here's one of Angus McNeill's drawings of
local tribesmen who were rounded up, one can
only imagine what that was like, to help pull
the boats up over the cataracts.
As you can see in this satellite photo, the
Nile has a big bend in it.
Kitchener decided to avoid an advance along
that difficult stretch of the river by building
a railroad across the Sahara Desert.
Construction of this railroad is one of the
most dramatic stories in Churchill's book.
Experts in England told Kitchner he couldn't
build a railway across the Sahara Desert in
time of war.
Kitchner decided he was going to build it
anyway, and his gamble paid off.
Getting to Khartoum was the hard part.
Once Kitchener's army reached the Dervish
capital, Abdullah's forces were no match for
them.
When Kitchener needed more engines than England
could provide, he bought them from America.
In the 1st edition of The River War, but not
in the 2nd, Churchill admits that American
engines with their interchangeable parts stood
up better than British ones.
By Spring 1898, the Anglo-Egyptian army had
reclaimed the Sudan along the Nile up to the
Atbara River, defeating a Dervish army there.
Colonel Frank Rhodes, he's the brother of
Cecil Rhodes, and he was wounded later in
the campaign, is the man on the left in this
picture with the pith helmet.
He was the original editor of The River War.
I don't think he spent as much time on it
as I have.
Churchill, a young cavalry officer serving
in India, had been following the campaign
attentively, and was eager to be part of it.
But it was a long way from India, and the
climax of the war was fast approaching.
Churchill enlisted help from his mother to
get to Egypt.
Churchill had had his baptism of fire in Cuba
with Spanish forces in 1895 on his 21st birthday.
This was his first experience at war.
I think Mr. Krauthamer got it a little out
of kilter last night.
Then Churchill had commanded troops for the
queen on the Indian frontier in 1897 in the
difficult border country of Pakistan near
the Afghan border, according to the modern
borders.
This campaign in India was the subject of
his first book, which had just been published.
By a stroke of luck, the Prime Minister, Lord
Salisbury, a man who had not always been friendly
to Churchill's father, happened to read Churchill's
book, and he invited him to Downing Street
for a chat.
He offered to help Churchill, and our author
quickly asked to go to the Sudan.
But Kitchener turned down the Prime Minister's
request, just as he had earlier turned down
the entreaties from Churchill's mother.
Only because the Anglo-Egyptian army was being
augmented, stiffened, by a few regular British
troops was Churchill able to take part in
the campaign, despite Kitchener's opposition.
He barely got to Africa in time for the climax.
Because Churchill was late, he had to hurry
to catch up with his regiment, tag end 21st
Lancers.
As he tells us in the 1st edition of The River
War, but not in the 2nd, he got lost in the
desert and he had to find his own way.
Fortunately, he didn't run into any Dervish
scouts while he was alone in the Sahara Desert,
he and his little pony.
But The River War does teach us plenty about
camels.
I wore my camel tie today.
For instance, it tells us how long a camel
can go without water, 5 days.
Then, if the camel drinks as much as possible
at a good water hole, maybe 5 days more, but
then the camel will die.
When Churchill and the army drew near to Khartoum,
he could hear the drums, and he could hear
the ombya, a horn made from an elephant's
trunk that helped keep up the good order and
the morale of Abdullah's army.
He was also impressed by the Dervish's battle
flags, which marked parts of the army commanded
by subordinate khalifas and emirs.
They reminded him of the banners he had seen
in the Bayeux Tapestry.
The climax of the campaign was the battle
of Omdurman.
The sirdar's gunboats and machine guns made
it an unequal battle for the Dervishes.
They were mown down by the hundreds.
Most of the British casualties, which were
far fewer, took place among the 21st Lancers,
who were ordered to charge into a water course
full of Dervishes.
In the hand-to-hand fighting, the odds were
much more even.
Churchill, who fought with a brand new Mauser
pistol instead of a sword because he'd injured
his shoulder in India, suffered no harm to
himself or to his horse.
Even before the Anglo-Egyptian army entered
the Dervish capital of Omdurman across the
river from Khartoum, Kitchener's gun boats
had done serious damage to the tomb of the
Mahdi.
Targeting the tomb, which of course was the
most notable and revered building in the capital,
was controversial, and Churchill was one of
the critics.
In the 1st edition of The River War, Churchill
writes a lengthy critique of Kitchener's bombardment
of the tomb.
Like many of the criticisms he wrote, it softened
in the abridged 2nd edition.
Churchill, who had noticed how the British
treated native religions in India with forbearance
and respect, thought it was a mistake to depart
from that prudent policy in the Sudan.
Kitchener had the Mahdi's skull made into
an inkwell, which he was happy to use until
Queen Victoria and Lord Cromer insisted on
having it properly re-buried in Wadi Halfa.
Churchill argues that if the British are going
to treat the Sudanese with savagery, then
they're no better than the Dervishes.
Eventually, after the 2nd World War, the British
allowed the Sudanese to rebuild the tomb of
the Mahdi, which became a place of pilgrimage.
Notice the little emblem on the cupola of
the tomb on the right-hand side, because it
will figure in the story a little later.
Because of his criticisms of Kitchener for
this and many other reasons, including the
treatment of the wounded on both sides, the
British and the Sudanese, Churchill damns
Kitchener by faint praise in the 1st edition
of The River War.
You can see this.
He says he occupies "certainly the third,
and possibly the second place."
I think he thought Cromer certainly had the
1st place, and perhaps Churchill meant that
maybe Lord Salisbury, who had allowed it all,
and to whom he dedicated the 1st edition of
The River War, had the 2nd place, leaving
Kitchener a poor third.
But in the 2nd edition, as you can read, he
softens that judgment.
Two days after the battle, a memorial service
was held for Charles Gordon in the ruins of
his palace in Khartoum, where Gordon's favorite
hymn Abide With Me was sung.
At that service, for the 1st time during the
campaign, the British raised a Union flag
larger than the Egyptian one.
But Churchill slept through it.
I thought you might enjoy seeing the title
pages and the new frontispieces of the 2 volumes
of the new edition of The River War.
I'm grateful to Lady Soames who wrote the
foreword to the new edition; to Richard Langworth,
who encouraged this project from the very
beginning; to Larry Arne who, before he was
president of Hillsdale, arranged for both
editions of the book to be scanned and offered
funding from the Equis Institute; to Bruce
Fingerhut, my publisher at St. Augustine Press;
to Allen Packwood and his staff at the Churchill
Archive Center for all their help and research;
to my collaborators Paul Courtney and Erica
Chenoweth; and to the Churchill Center for
steady support and assistance.
Three days after the battle, Churchill rode
over the battlefield with a Scottish officer,
Lord Tullibardine, the son of the Duke of
Atholl.
In 1 of the most unforgettable chapters in
the book, which is entirely omitted from the
2nd edition, Churchill describes the suffering
of the wounded Dervishes, who were neglected,
and still dying on the battle field 3 days
after the battle in that heat.
His colleague was able to extract the bullet
from the knee of 1 of them as they went on,
and Churchill and Lord Tullibardine tried
to give water to the sufferers on the battlefield
until their canteens ran dry.
Later Tullibardine enlisted help from his
friends, not including Churchill as far as
I can see, in carrying spoils of the campaign
back to his castle in the Scottish Highlands,
where they decorate the banqueting hall.
He also removed a copper emblem from the top
of that cupola of the Mahdi's tomb, and installed
it on the clock tower of his castle.
His letter to the family shows where the emblem
was taken down from the top of the tomb.
Unfortunately, later his clock tower burned
down and the emblem melted in the fire.
So what you see in the photo is a reconstruction
of the tower and a replica of the emblem that
used to be at the top of the tomb in Omdurman.
Churchill left the Sudan soon after the battle,
taking Nile steamers and the desert railway
north.
At a station in the desert the train broke
down.
Wen the Arab engine driver attributed the
delay to Allah, discerning some wise purpose
in the delay, a lieutenant, or as the British
say, a leftenant of the Grenadier guards who
had experience driving trains, Frederick Harvey
Bathurst, rolled up his sleeves and got the
engine moving again.
Some of the officers thought that conduct
was unbecoming to a British gentleman.
But Churchill admires his ability.
This episode provoked a Churchillian effusion
in a chapter of the 1st edition that is omitted
in the 2nd edition.
This quotation has flown around the internet
nonstop ever since 9-11.
People have looked it up in The River War.
They can't find it.
That's because they only have the abridged
version of the book.
Of course, this passage would now be considered
politically incorrect.
Churchill may have left it out of the 2nd
edition because he thought it impolitic.
After all, the British Empire had many Muslim
subjects.
Last year a British politician of sorts was
even arrested for quoting this passage in
public.
Britain doesn't have a 1st Amendment.
But look, if you read the quotation, it's
hard to object to Churchill's criticism of
people who treat women as property.
The passage, which people looked for in vain
in the abridged edition, will be restored,
of course, in the new one.
The train did get moving again and Churchill
returned to Cairo with a fellow officer who
had been wounded.
In My Early Life, you can read the story of
how Churchill had to have a little bit of
skin from his arm sawed off to help provide
a skin graft to Richard Molyneux.
I wanted you to read this because here's another
passage, this time from an early chapter of
The River War, which did survive the editing,
with Churchill's curious spelling of development,
which was changed in the 2nd edition, and
a drawing by Angus McNiell in the 1st edition
that some people may think no less objectionable.
In fact, some people have argued that this
passage and others like it show that Churchill
was a racist.
The truth is more complicated and more o Churchill's
credit.
He begins The River War by reflecting the
usual Victorian prejudice against black people.
But then, as the book goes on, he deliberately
undermines it.
By the end of the book, having rejected the
usual prejudice, Churchill argues that the
10th Sudanese, which is a black regiment in
the Anglo-Egyptian army, ranks with the best
troops of the Empire, British or native.
I've highlighted that passage, but let me
show it to you bigger, and I hope some of
you can read it.
You'll see that in this Churchill even argues
that the charge these black troops made in
the 10th Sudanese in a subsequent battle of
the war after Churchill and most of the British
troops had returned to the UK, was finer than
the charge of the 21st Lancers at Omdurman.
Against the usual view among British officers
that black soldiers wouldn't make good cavalry
troopers, Churchill includes a footnote approving
of the formation of black squadrons of cavalry.
His aim is to weaken prejudice by offering
examples that disprove it, and encouraging
opportunities that have been denied to black
troops on account of prejudices up till now.
To return to the Dervish soldiers, Churchill
denies that they were mad fanatics for pitting
their trashy weapons against the machine guns
and the gun boats of a far more advanced enemy.
You see what he says?
He claims that these were as brave men as
ever walked the earth.
He claims that they fought to the death because
they were noble and honorable.
His magnanimity to a defeated enemy was controversial
when he published it.
But it remained his lifelong view.
Here is Churchill, much older, inspecting
bomb damage in London during the Blitz.
Here on the left in red is Churchill, with
Churchillian bravery and oratory, in his 20s,
in the pages of The River War, anticipating
Britain's finest hour more than 4 decades
before he became Prime Minister.
Churchill spent a year after the campaign
writing The River War, using his dispatches
from the Morning Post as raw material, but
also studying the history of the Sudan.
He considered how Britain had changed its
future by the reconquest, and he asked whether
that change would help or hurt the people
of the Sudan.
He is lukewarm about imperialism, grand projects
of development, higher education, Christian
missionary work, and grasping entrepreneurs
in the Sudan.
He thinks what the country needs is very small
development projects like digging wells, and
that the country is going to need a long time
to recover from the war.
Churchill's adventures in the South African
war where he was captured and imprisoned by
the Boers, but managed to escape and return
to friendly territory, made him famous.
Before long he was elected to the House of
Commons, where he took his seat as a member
of parliament for Oldham early in 1901.
But look at this, more than half a century
later, nearing the end of his political career,
in his second prime ministry, in October 1952,
Churchill welcomed the posthumous son of the
Mahdi, who left 1 of his new wives pregnant
when he died.
This man came to #10 Downing Street in anticipation
of Sudanese independence, which was granted
on January 1st, 1956.
Since then, the Sudan has had a succession
of regimes, 1 of which in the '80s included
other descendants of the Mahdi.
I'm afraid most of those regimes have been
thuggish, terrible regimes, including the
one that's in power right now.
Thank you for your kind attention.
I think the floor is now open for questions.
You know, I think this book is a wonderful
opportunity for somebody who wants to understand
one of the challenges that Charles Krauthamer
was talking about that America faces now.
I know it's required reading in some of our
nation's military colleges.
I going to the US Naval War College next week
to speak about it.
Speaker 3: What was the most surprising thing
you've learned after doing this new edition?
What was 1 thing that stood out?
James Muller: Well, there are many interesting
things I learned.
I learned a lot about how Churchill writes.
I learned, for instance, that mostly he writes
on the basis of what he remembers.
Though he did look up some of these quotations
and references, mostly he simply remembered
them.
His memory was amazing, as had been his father's.
His father had almost a photographic memory.
But it wasn't perfect.
So occasionally he gets a quotation a little
bit wrong.
Very often, he doesn't tell you where the
quotation comes from, and it's been my ambition
to try to track down the source of every quotation
in the book, and to give identifications in
footnotes of everyone Churchill mentions in
the book, which has occasioned a great deal
of detective work, and it's been quite a lot
of fun.
What I've discovered there is that Churchill
doesn't ever want to quote a passage that
isn't written up to his own standard, and
so often he will improve the English of the
writing when he quotes something.
So that was one interesting thing I learned.
I mean, there were many others.
I think learning about the circumstances of
this quotation on Islam, which Churchill wrote
when he was sort of frustrated by being stuck
in the desert, was an interesting thing to
discover.
Of course, tracking down the dispatches that
Churchill wrote, which were the original version
of some of the parts of the book, was interesting,
too.
Those were not available or known in their
manuscript version when the official biography
was written.
They appeared, finally, in the 1980s, in the
late 1980s, in the archive at the University
of Leeds.
Of course, the dispatches had been published
in the newspapers, and they'd been published
again several times in book form.
But the book version was based only on the
newspaper version, and the newspaper editor
changed what Churchill rote in many, many
ways and left out things.
So in the new edition there's quite a long
appendix in the 2nd volume that has, for the
1st time, the full version of the dispatches
as Churchill wrote them, published and compared
to the newspaper version.
Those of you who know all about The River
War and have read the 2-volume version will
find that appendix very interesting.
Unless you have been to Leeds and read the
original hand-written dispatches there.
Fourteen of them survive.
One of them doesn't.
That was certainly a wonderful discovery.
I discovered it when I was in London.
I got on a train to Leeds, not knowing how
far it was to Leeds.
Had to come back that night to get my suitcases
to spend another couple of days transcribing
those 15 dispatches.
Then I had a student who learned to read Churchill's
handwriting very well by hard knocks, who
helped me proofread it and make sure we got
every comma and misspelled word right.
Churchill's spelling wasn't too great when
he wrote these dispatches.
Speaker 4: Churchill is mentioned, along with
Lincoln and Washington.
In books on Lincoln I have noticed metaphors,
biblical metaphors in his writings, and comments
on Christianity.
We've heard comments on Islam by Churchill.
What did he have to say about Christianity,
or his understanding?
James Muller: Churchill tells us in The River
War, which was written much later, in the
1930s, that in his youth he went through a
violent anti-religious phase, which if it
had continued, would have made him obnoxious.
In The River War you can see signs of that.
He mentions that Christianity, if it had not
been sheltered in the strong arms of science,
against which it struggled in vain, might
have been no match for the military forces
of Islam.
He has some other things to say, too.
I mentioned his reservations about Gordon's
confidence that because he was a Christian
hero his martyrdom would somehow be repaid
in heaven.
Churchill seems to think this was a most imprudent
way of trying to save the lives of the Europeans
in Khartoum, most of whom perished when the
city was taken over by the Dervishes.
Later, of course, Churchill softened his statements
on Christianity, and that's a long, interesting,
and complicated subject, about which our next
speaker has spoken after careful research.
I don't know if he'll talk about it today.
But I recommend his talk, if you get hold
of it, on that subject.
Though I probably have a few disagreements
with bits of it.
Speaker 5: Sir?
James Muller: Yes.
Speaker 5: I wonder if Winston Churchill ever
forecast or speculated on general warfare
between Islamic armies and the armies of the
Christian, or Judeo-Christian West.
James Muller: Well, I think he was lucky enough
to live in a time when the aspirations, let's
say, of the Mahdi to take over the whole world
and submit it to Islam were obviously unrealistic.
I think Queen Victoria, when she got his letter
asking her to renounce Christianity and become
a Musim, probably had a good laugh about it.
But Churchill certainly later in his career,
and not much later, was very interested in
the reforms that were attempted by those who
called themselves the Young Turks in Turkey,
to try to establish a Turkish state on a secular
basis, a state that would have a majority
Muslim population, an overwhelmingly majority
Muslim population, but with strong Christian
population and populations of other religions,
Zoroastrians and various branches of Islam
and Christian believers.
He was discouraged, of course, when the Turk
chose the wrong side in the 1st World War,
perhaps somewhat pleased by the eventual launching
of the Turkish Republic under Ataturk, and
I think would be watching closely the changes
that are going forward in Turkey right now.
Speaker 6: This will be our final question.
Speaker 7: Your exhaustive research, I've
just got 1 quick question for you.
Given that Winston Churchill, his early career,
he had to have interactions, understandings
of Cecil Rhodes, what can you tell us about
that interaction?
What was Churchill's opinion of Rhodes with
the control over Cape Colony, aka South Africa?
James Muller: I went to South Africa in 1993,
just at the time when the changes in the country
were about to occur.
What had been the house in Cape Town of the
President of South Africa, Declerc, which
was the house Cecil Rhodes built for himself
in Cape Town, with its 14-foot long granite
bathtub on the 2nd floor, 1 can only imagine
how many men had to haul that up the stairs
to install it.
That house was about to become Nelson Mandela's
house.
I was interested in Churchill's contact with
Cecil Rhodes, who was, of course, very important,
not just for Rhodes scholarships in America,
but even more for the British Empire.
Churchill didn't know Cecil Rhodes much.
He knew his brother because of his contact
with him in this campaign, very much better.
But when he went to South Africa, he had a
number of meals at Rhodes' house.
Cecil Rhodes wasn't there then, though.
Churchill did have a great deal to do with
the settlement between Boers and Britains
who had launched 2 colonies each on the southern
tip of Africa in previous centuries, after
the South African war, which he participated
in.
One of his regrets was that 1 of the differences
between the Boers and the Britains was their
treatment of the indigenous population.
The compromise that was made with the Boers,
in order to form the Union of South Africa
in 1906, was to some degree at the expense,
of course, of the black citizens of the country.
That wasn't really remedied until much, much
later, until the 1990s.
Unfortunately, the results of that in terms
of making a regime that guarantees the rights
and liberties of the people of that country,
are very mixed.
More successful, probably, than in the Sudan,
but still not very encouraging.
This idea that people should be ruled by a
tyrant of their own race, color, and creed,
and that that's adequate to secure happiness
and to protect liberty, is just plain silly.
We've got to get over that before the countries
of Africa, which deserve the opportunity for
self-government and for freedom, including
freedom of commerce, have a chance to develop
and improve themselves in the way they can.
I think 1 of the most notable and obvious
things about Churchill's book is that though
he's not rosy eyed or simple minded about
the obstacles that Africans, and specifically
people in the Sudan will face in bringing
their country into the modern world, he thinks
it's possible, and he thinks it's possible
for them to do it.
He thinks they would have done it even if
the British had not intervened.
It would have taken longer, he admits.
He's of 2 minds about whether it would have
worked out better.
But at any rate, he thinks Britain has a very
serious obligation now, in 1898, after the
reconquest, to do its best for the people
of the Sudan.
He talks about that in the last chapter of
the book, which is left out of the 2nd edition.
Thank you very much.